If we want to change the location of a point, we can use a translation matrix.
This matrix has the translation movement put in the top three positions of the
last column. The rest of the matrix looks the same as the identity matrix. If
you multiply a point by this matrix, the one coordinate in the last position of
the vector multiplies each translation value in turn. This has the effect of
taking the original point. And adding the translation to it. This may seem like
a convoluted way to add a vector to a point, but you'll soon see that many other
transforms can be combined and stored in this matrix, translations among them.
With a single matrix multiply, you can then perform any number of
transformations. Say instead you multiply a vector by this matrix. You'll get
the same vector back. The fourth coordinate of the vector is zero. So for all
the translation values that are multiplied by zero, and so ignored. This makes
sense. A vector does not have a location so it can not be translated. The only
thing mentioning at this point is that this type of matrix and vector notation
Is called column-major form. There is also a row-major form for notation where
the coordinates are written out in a row. The vector row is multiplied by each
column of the matrix in turn. Personally, this is how I learned matrices 30
years ago. Microsoft's DirectX uses this form. The story I heard as to why row
vectors became popular was due to the influence of Steve Koons. He wrote some
influential papers on transformations for computer graphics back in the 1960s.
He said he said he used draw vectors in those papers because it was easier for
the stenographers to type the translation values along the bottom of the matrix
rather than having to type them in the column. All that said, web GL uses
column-major notation. In this convention is also the norm in most publications,
so that's all we use here. Either form is fine, they're both just a way writing
down the math. I mostly want you to be aware that there's another form out there
called row major. The good news is that, internally, Web GL and DirectX
ultimately store the translation values in the same locations in memory. If you
go look at any matrix in memory. You'll see that the last four values are the
three translation values, and then a one.